merci nous allons démarrer
c'est vrai que nous sommes un moment de
notre semaine un petit peu compliqué
avec des problèmes de circulation de
d'avion de train etc dans les horaires
ont pu être bouleversés voire même
supprimer donc on a pas mal d'entre nous
qui ne sont pas là aujourd'hui
l'important c'est de vous écouter de
vous entendre et d'échanger alors voilà
je voudrais d'abord excuser le président
et c'est d'ailleurs pour cette raison
qu'il n'est pas là aujourd'hui de notre
mission puisque il est obligé de prendre
un moyen de transport plutôt que prévu
voilà nous poursuivons les travaux de
notre mission d'information sur le
développement d'une filière de
biocarburant carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert en abordant
cet après-midi les enjeux de la filière
automobile
nous avons la chance de recevoir tout
d'abord monsieur Marc portueux directeur
donc général de la plateforme automobile
et Monsieur Nicolas Le Bigot qui nous
rejoindra dès que possible et qui
lui-même est directeur des affaires
environnementales techniques et
réglementaire de la PFA la plateforme
automobile rassemble l'ensemble de la
filière automobile en France qu'il
s'agisse des constructeurs des
équipementsiers des sous-traitants et
des autres acteurs de la mobilité
la pvfa représente quelques 4000
entreprises du secteur automobile et
s'appuie sur le réseau des associations
régionales de l'industrie automobile
ainsi que sur les pôles de compétitivité
plusieurs membres de la mission avaient
ainsi pu échanger avec le cluster Kara
lors de notre déplacement à Lyon
je rappelle que cette réunion est captée
monsieur le directeur est diffusé en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat sur
lequel d'ailleurs elle pourra ensuite
être consultée en vidéo à la demande de
celui qui le souhaitera messieurs notre
mission
il n'y a pas de dame non messieurs notre
émission d'information comprend des
membres issus de différentes commissions
qui représentent l'ensemble des groupes
politiques du Sénat le développement des
filières de biocarburant de carburant
synthétique durable et d'hydrogène vert
représente nous savons tous un enjeu
important pour permettre à la France et
à l'Union européenne d'atteindre
l'objectif de neutralité carbone à
l'horizon 2050 mais aussi pour notre
souveraineté la compétitivité de notre
économie
la fin de la commercialisation des
véhicules légers fonctionnant avec un
moteur thermique à compter de 2035 a été
au centre des discussions européennes
récentes l'Allemagne ayant notamment
plaidé au cours de la dernière ligne
droite en faveur des carburants
synthétiques durable quant aux objectifs
des missions pour les poids lourds les
discussions ont commencé plus
tardivement et se poursuivent pour
aborder
c'est poursuivre plus aborderez donc
certainement les enjeux du basculement
vers l'électricité pour les véhicules
légers nous sommes nombreux à nous
interroger d'ailleurs sur les impacts de
cette mesure tant pour la filière
automobile dans son ensemble que pour
les usagers
nous nous interrogeons également sur les
modalités de la transition vers ce
nouveau paradigme et sur les amoniations
éventuelles du cadre européen qui
pourrait intervenir à l'occasion de la
clause de revoyure qui est prévue en
2026 nous avons compris par ailleurs que
l'électricité ne permettrait pas de
couvrir tous les besoins de la filière
automobile et que le recours à d'autres
types de carburants ou de vecteurs
énergétique serait nécessaire pour
certains types de véhicules ou d'usage
notre rapporteur monsieur Vincent
capocanellas vous a adressé un
questionnaire qui peut vous servir de
guide mais vous pouvez introduire votre
propos comme vous le souhaitez je
passerai ensuite la parole d'organes à
notre rapporteur puis à l'ensemble de
mes collègues ici présents afin qu'il
puisse vous relancer vous poser un
certain nombre de questions
vous pourrez nous transmettre bien
évidemment
ultérieurement des réponses écrites aux
questions qui vous ont été adressées et
pour lequel vous n'auriez peut-être pas
le temps de répondre monsieur Mathurin
je vous aide la parole pour une
quinzaine de minutes mais je voudrais
saluer donc l'arrivée de Monsieur de
Bigot voilà que j'ai présenté et voilà
nous savons nord de marche monsieur
marturux vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur décédateur mesdames et
messieurs
ravi d'avoir l'occasion voilà de cet
échange avec vous sur un beau sujet on a
bien reçu le questionnaire on vous
apportera d'ailleurs vraiment des
éléments assez détaillés puisque
beaucoup des questions sont au cœur de
nos actions nos préoccupations puisqu'à
la PFA on est notamment là pour
accompagner toute cette mutation donc ce
que je me propose peut-être en deux mots
d'abord c'est pour appeler un petit peu
la situation effectivement de la filière
et et par rapport à la trajectoire que
vous avez rappelé du ban en 2035 et
ensuite devenir un peu plus précisément
sur les questions des biocarburants des
if you etc et on répondra bien
évidemment à vos questions d'abord je
commencerai peut-être en indiquant que
l'automobile c'est probablement le seul
secteur malheureusement qui depuis la
crise covid n'a pas retrouvé et loin de
là c'est niveau d'activité d'avant on a
vraiment connu une succession de crise
covid ensuite crise des semis
conducteurs la guerre en Ukraine avec
des conséquences assez lourdes sur
l'explosion du coût des matières
premières aujourd'hui de l'énergie et
c'est vrai que on a connu donc une chute
historique du marché de plus de 30 % on
remonte un petit peu en ce début d'année
2023 parce que notamment les crises de
semi-conducteurs sont en train de
s'alléger mais on est encore à -25% par
rapport à 2019 donc c'est vrai qu'on est
dans un contexte conjoncturel qui est
quand même compliqué et dans le cadre de
ce contexte on est effectivement sur une
mutation sans précédent d'aller vers
l'électrique le tout électrique en 2035
je vais pas revenir sur tous les débats
qu'il y a eu mais ce qui est certain
c'est que
au niveau de l'automobile on est
totalement d'accord pour aller vers
l'électrique qui est une très bonne
solution pour toute une série d'usages
il y a aucun doute là-dessus et
l'industrie s'est résolument engagé
là-dedans par contre et on l'avait dit
assez clairement dans le cadre des
négociations européennes notamment au
cours du premier semestre d'année 2022
on est très interrogatif sur enfer la
solution unique
pour tous les usages sachant on pourra y
revenir qu'on considère à la fois que
solution unique est toujours quand même
une question et et que ça soit les
pouvoirs publics finalement imposent la
technologie
interpelle un peu et il y a beaucoup de
conditions à réunir pour effectivement
atteindre ce résultat et qui ne
dépendent pas que de la filière
automobile mais également de toute une
série d'éléments d'environnement sur
lequel on pourra revenir en matière de
souveraineté les enjeux de prix un des
véhicules qui posent quand même des
questions aujourd'hui voilà donc ça
c'était un peu le rappel on est donc on
a engagé des investissements absolument
considérables dans les détrites je
rappelle qu'en ce début d'année 2023 on
est à peu près à 15 % un peu plus de 15
% de part de marché de l'électrique
on est à 23% quand on rajoute les
hybrides rechargeables et on est à peu
près à 45% si on rajoute tous les types
d'hybrides un fou d'hybrides miles
d'hybride qu'on appelle voilà donc la
transition est clairement engagée mais
ce que je voudrais peut-être quand même
rajouter c'est que elle n'est pas encore
dans un stade où c'est naturel et on va
de façon naturelle vers effectivement le
tout électrique on le voit d'ailleurs en
ce début d'année il y a quand même un
certain tassement et c'est vrai que les
véhicules électriques aujourd'hui ont
été vendus beaucoup à des gens qui ont
au moins de voitures qui
ont des possibilités pour se recharger
qu'on des revenus insuffisants et c'est
vrai que un des enjeux aujourd'hui pour
aller vers les objectifs que nous devons
tenir c'est de pouvoir toucher des
populations de plus en plus larges dans
un contexte qui n'est pas facile voilà
et que la trajectoire qui nous est
imposée par la réglementation européenne
conduit à viser à peu près 50% au moins
de véhicules 100% électrique en 2030
donc très prochainement ça doit avancer
extrêmement vite donc on pourra revenir
là-dessus mais c'est vrai qu'on a encore
beaucoup de défis à relever et
j'ajouterai peut-être quand même que on
a le sentiment que les messages qu'on dû
être donnés à l'automne que on aurait
peut-être pas assez d'électricité
pendant l'hiver et que ça va durer sans
doute un certain nombre d'hiver n'est
pas évidemment à se convaincre que le
basculement vers le véhicule électrique
est
nécessairement le bon choix mais soyons
clairs nous on est parti et on doit
réussir clairement pour nous le choix de
l'électrique et derrière nous on est
aujourd'hui parti alors vous avez évoqué
par rapport à ce bande 2030
la demande la revendication des
Allemands en particulier mais d'un
certain nombre d'autres pays dont
l'Italie également et quelques autres
pays
de remettre un peu en question le tout
électrique comme solution unique avec
notamment l'ouverture à des véhicules
thermiques mais qui fonctionneraient
avec des carburants neutres en carbone
donc notamment les if you n'ont pas
revenir après sur le vocabulaire de
toutes les catégories je pense vous avez
déjà entendu beaucoup de choses sur de
quoi on parle puisqu'il y a quand même
beaucoup de beaucoup de questionnements
par rapport à ça moi la première chose
que je voudrais dire c'est que cette
petite ouverture qui a été
actée
et qui va se traduire un par un certain
nombre de textes à venir
fondamentalement ne change pas la donne
à ce stade pour les constructeurs et les
constructeurs généralistes que sont
notamment nos deux constructeurs
français je dirais à la fois parce
qu'ils sont engagés dans cette
trajectoire d'investissement massifs
vers l'électrique et
plus vite il réussissent à aller
effectivement vers des parts de plus en
plus importantes finalement aujourd'hui
au regard de ses investissements et au
regard des objectifs à des obligations
qui leur sont imposés en soi une bonne
chose et je dirais deuxièmement cette
petite ouverture elle elle contient
beaucoup d'incertitudes du point de vue
un des constructeurs et de la filière
automobile sur la réalité du potentiel
de marcher possible
de ces carburants de Tran carbone à la
fois parce que à ce stade on est dans
l'attente de précision sur le plan
réglementaire c'est quoi exactement qui
va être autorisé et là-dessus donc ce
que l'on sait c'est que la Commission
européenne doit présenter deux textes
l'un normalement juin l'autre en
septembre le premier c'est en fait un
acte délégué dans le cadre de la
réglementation sur Euro 6 et qui doit
préciser
c'est quoi un carburant de en carbone et
là on pourra y venir parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de débats possibles sur c'est
plus ou moins restreint comme définition
et deuxièmement c'est quoi un véhicule
thermique qui ne fonctionnerait
exclusivement qu'avec des carburants
neutre en carbone puisque c'est des deux
conditions donc c'est des défis
techniquement de quoi on parle et il y a
un deuxième acte qui serait présenté
donc plutôt à la rentrée à l'automne qui
est plutôt là cette fois dans le cadre
de la réglementation sur le CO2
puisqu'il s'agit justement d'ouvrir la
possibilité ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui d'ouvrir la possibilité
d'autoriser au-delà de 2035 des
véhicules thermiques qui ne
fonctionneraient qu'avec des carburants
de en carbone donc premier point disons
d'incertitude c'est qu'est-ce que vont
dire précisément ces textes et on y
reviendra certainement donc voilà sur
c'est quoi l'ouverture
if you de façon très très stricte on
reviendra un peu sur les définitions
voir plus large les Italiens
souhaiteraient quelque chose d'assez
large bon voilà il va y avoir des débats
sans doute assez important là-dessus
donc c'est quand même une première
source d'incertitude sur de quoi on
parle et le deuxième deuxième esprit
c'est évidemment est-ce que
l'automobile aurait disons de façon
disponible suffisamment de biocarburant
ou de fuel correspondant à la définition
qui sera définie
on est quand même une industrie de masse
est-ce que il y aura suffisamment de
gisements insuffisamment de production
sachant qu'on sait très bien que en
priorité ce qui sera produit sera
probablement pour des secteurs qui ont
moins d'alternatives que l'automobile en
particulier l'aéronautique peut-être le
maritime donc pour nous c'est évidemment
une question à la fois le volume qui
sera réellement disponible et
le prix aussi qui n'est pas à ce stade
défini donc ça c'est juste pour vous
dire voilà à ce stade et vous aurez je
crois une audition de représentant de
stellantis qui travaille évidemment
beaucoup avec nous également donc qui
vous pourra voilà après qui pourra aussi
disons vous préciser un peu la position
mais à ce stade voilà de toute façon la
trajectoire est quand même toujours
d'aller
vraiment fortement évidemment vers
l'électrique après cette petite
ouverture néanmoins on le voit de façon
positive pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est on a toujours plaidé pour
de la diversité technologique pour que
la réglementation soit neutre le plus
possible par rapport à la technologie à
choisir par rapport à des objectifs qui
sont donnés et c'est vrai que ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur les questions
qu'on a aujourd'hui sur l'acceptabilité
de l'électrique pour tous les usages et
quand même une question donc cette
ouverture potentielle intrinsèquement va
dans le sens de ce qu'on a toujours un
peu défendu la deuxième chose surtout
c'est que nécessairement cette question
de carburant Neutra carbone ouvre je
dirais enfin une approche qui est en
analyse de cycle de vie ce qu'on a
beaucoup regretté dans la réglementation
européenne pour les véhicules c'est que
on a fixé des objectifs qui ne
concernent que
les émissions de COD à l'usage donc du
réservoir à la roue uniquement et non
pas en analyse de cycle de vie complet
alors encore une fois ça remettant en
cause le fait que l'électrique a un très
bon bilan y compris en ACI de cycle de
vie pour toute une série d'usage il y a
aucun doute là-dessus et il y a aucune
ambiguïté pour nous par contre on reste
convaincus qui comprit sur un plan
environnemental et des missions de CO2
en analyse de cycle de vie il y a un
certain nombre de cas d'usages pour
lequel des alternatives pourraient être
franchement intéressant on a toujours
plaidé pour garder la possibilité dans
certains usages notamment des hybrides
rechargeables c'est à dire des véhicules
pour le trajet quotidien fonctionne
exclusivement à l'électrique
il n'a pas besoin de très grosses
batteries le grand avantage un
déshybride rechargeable c'est d'avoir
des batteries beaucoup plus modestes que
des 100% électrique qui ont besoin
d'avoir une grosse autonomie donc ça
c'est un point important parce que pour
le coup une batterie il y a une
empreinte carbone importante pour la
fabrication de la batterie donc des
véhicules qu'on a une petite batterie et
lorsqu'il est nécessaire de faire des
trajets plus longs et ben oui on utilise
le thermique qui pourrait fonctionner
avec des carburants relativement bas
carbone qui pourrait avoir un bilan tout
à fait intéressant et qui par ailleurs
éviterait quand même un peu la question
qu'on a c'est que si on bascule tout
tout électrique en terme
d'infrastructures de recharge et
notamment pour gérer des pointes c'est
quand même quelque chose qui va être
compliqué d'ailleurs ça demande à
dimensionnement d'infrastructure qui est
important donc voilà on avait donc en
tout cas de rentrer dans un raisonnement
analyse de cycle de vie est intéressant
pour nous et je dirais le troisième
argument pour nous
plutôt favorable à l'ouverture de ce
débat c'est que si ça peut permettre de
stimuler parce qu'il y aurait des
perspectives de déboucher les
investissements à faire pour
effectivement produire davantage de
carburant bas carbone
indépendamment de notre échéance 2035 ce
qui est clair c'est que dans notre
feuille de route de décarbonation un peu
globale on voit bien que s'intéresser
aux véhicules neufs et de forcer un
départ de marché de plus en plus
importantes vers l'électrique c'est un
aspect mais si on veut assez rapidement
baisser les missions de CO2 faut
s'intéresser aussi au parc existant de
véhicules et que si on arrive à mettre
sur le marché des carburants bas carbone
compatible avec les motorisations qui
existent aujourd'hui sur le marché c'est
vrai qu'on a rapidement des résultats en
termes de baisse des émissions de CO2
qui sont importantes parce que je
rappelle on vend aujourd'hui un peu
moins de 2 millions de véhicules par an
9 et on a un parc de 44 millions de
véhicules à peu près 38 millions de
véhicules particuliers à peu près 6
millions de véhicules utilitaires légers
donc c'est sûr que ce parc est il met du
temps
à évolué puisque un véhicule ça 15 ans
de durée de vie
à peu près enfin voilà voire plus bien
entendu et donc voilà c'est vrai que
d'avoir un équilibre entre la
préoccupation sur les véhicules neufs
c'est nécessaire bien sûr mais aussi sur
les les véhicules existants c'est c'est
quelque chose qui peut être important et
par rapport à ça mais on reviendra
dessus certainement de façon plus
précise vous savez qu'il y a un cadre
régleur menteur européen donc les les
réglementations raides de et maintenant
on va voir red 3 qui prévoit voilà des
développements de carburant de
biocarburant en proportion avec des
plafonds aussi notamment pour éviter la
concurrence par rapport à l'alimentaire
pour les parties de biocarburant de
première génération et qui prévoit
d'autres c'est vrai que en ce qui nous
concerne on arriverait à prendre des
décisions qui permettraient un peu de
d'aller au maximum de ce que c'est
réglementations permettent de faire ça
aurait un effet positif sur la
décarbonation du transport routier
à la fois vécu de léger et véhicules
lourd et sur les véhicules lourds
effectivement on a aujourd'hui depuis
février une proposition de la Commission
européenne pour accélérer la trajectoire
de baisse des émissions de CO2 qui doit
conduire en 2040 à - 90% des émissions
de CO2 toujours dans la même logique
uniquement les émissions du réservoir à
la route donc uniquement à l'usage bon
moins 90%, c'est de la même façon que
pour les véhicules légers une
trajectoire qui doit s'accélérer
énormément vers des véhicules zéro
émission or
des écarts de prix sont encore plus
importants que pour les véhicules
particuliers pour aller basculer soif
vers des véhicules électriques à
batterie soit à hydrogène et là encore
il y a des espaces qui nous semblent
potentiellement intéressants dans des
alternatives avec des carburants qui
seraient de plus en plus bas carbone
donc voilà ce président peut-être en
terme un peu généraux à ce stade notre
positionnement c'est-à-dire honnêtement
on est vers l'électrique et on va pas
dévier de cette trajectoire aujourd'hui
parce que les investissements sont
engagés parce que la réglementation de
toute façon nous impose et que le bilan
énergétique d'ailleurs d'un véhicule à
batterie électrique à batterie est
intéressante il y a un bon rendement
énergétique donc ça a du sens pour
beaucoup d'usage
mais par contre on est quand même
interrogatif sur un certain nombre
d'usage sur l'acceptabilité pour un
certain nombre d'usage et dans ces
cas-là tout ce qui peut être des
ouvertures qui ne sont pas
contradictoires avec l'objectif
environnemental de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique nous paraissent
intéressantes vraiment à étudier
simplement
faut que les décisions elles soient
assez rapide et j'ajouterai peut-être
comme dernier élément que vous avez
évoqué la clause de revoyure qui est
prévue je crois 2026 voilà par rapport
aux bannes 2035
en tout état de cause que cette clause
revoyure soit l'occasion de réouvrir un
peu le débat d'un raisonnement en
analyse de cycle de vie serait utile
parce que aujourd'hui
pour un constructeur il a une obligation
de baisser très très fortement les
émissions moyennes de CO2 par kilomètre
parcourus uniquement du réservoir à la
roue donc le fait que le véhicule il
fonctionne éventuellement avec des
carburants très bas carbone n'a aucun
intérêt au regard de cette
réglementation donc il y a aucun
incitatif pour ça et c'est vrai que
d'arriver dans le cadre de la clause de
revoyure à rouvrir le débat pour avoir
un
analyse plus large qui nous paraît plus
cohérente globalement avec l'objectif
de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique parce que c'est bien les
émissions globales qui font regarder est
un des enjeux pour nous de cette clause
de revoyure et qu'à la limite le petit
épisode qu'on a eu récemment sur les if
Youle va nécessairement conduire à
ouvrir plus explicitement le débat voilà
monsieur le Président peut-être comme
premier élément donc c'est pas comme si
j'étais on va peut-être
entendre les deux intervenants sur le
rapporteur
où est-ce qu'on ouvre le débat non je
pense que ça peut être aussi bien que
vous continuez monsieur Bigot
j'ai pas beaucoup de choses à apporter
mais mais voilà on peut peut-être ouvrir
le débat si vous avez des questions un
échange qui doit être facile voilà très
bien donc Monsieur Le Bigot vous avez
les paroles
non l'idée peut-être un voilà parce que
on avait prévu c'est moi je fais un peu
le cadre général et par contre Nicolas
Le Bilot va nous être très utile du coup
va nous être très utile pour répondre à
des questions voilà je pense que c'est
une question si monsieur le rapporteur
me le permet
qu'est-ce qui vous laisse penser que on
va dans le bon chemin quand on dit que
on va sur le tout électrique
moi j'ai bien vu quand même une crise
que nous avons eu vous avez cité le mois
de novembre décembre on a eu aussi le
mois de janvier et que bien évidemment
demain après-demain on ne sait pas ce
qui peut se passer est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
on n'a pas aujourd'hui cette fragilité
devant nous ce mur dans lequel on risque
de rentrer à vive allure voilà j'ai une
deuxième question j'ai eu la chance
aujourd'hui de prendre deux moyens de
transport public enfin de taxis j'ai
pris un véhicule hybride
et je lui posais la question une très
belle voiture
Toyota mais bon modèle et je lui
demandais ce qu'il pensait de son
véhicule il me dit je suis très content
à Paris mais alors dès que je vais en
week-end quelque part dès que je
transporte ma famille c'est une
catastrophe parce que je fais une
consommation d'essence
tout à fait hors norme et puis je suis
revenu avec un autre taxi du rendez-vous
où j'étais et je suis monté pour la
première fois dans une Tesla
et alors là je suis tombé sur un
chauffeur qui m'a dit écoutez jamais
plus je rachèterai un véhicule comme
celui-là parce que je suis beaucoup trop
embêté d'abord au-delà du fait que c'est
complètement inconfortable cette
véhicule et je l'ai vérifié vous êtes
incapable d'écrire un SMS en tout cas à
Paris quand vous êtes assis dans le
véhicule et de sortir par la bonne porte
bon mais ceci étant il dit c'est très
compliqué aussi dès qu'on sort du milieu
urbain dans le choix qu'on doit faire
sur les circuits routiers que l'on doit
prendre voilà alors c'est une question
que je voulais savoir est-ce que votre
votre vision par rapport aux tout
électrique est une chose sensée
aujourd'hui ou est-ce qu'il faut pas
plutôt aller vers une orientation vers
un bouquet d'énergie qui nous
permettrait d'avoir et de conserver le
moteur thermique
je veux être très pragmatique dans ma
réponse on s'est battu beaucoup
préserver de la diversité technologique
pour préserver différentes énergies on
sait battus beaucoup on a eu énormément
d'échanges au niveau national au niveau
européen parce qu'effectivement et vous
l'avez beaucoup entendu il y a eu
beaucoup de questionsnements quand même
sur encore une fois on nous a un peu
reproché alors nous collectivement
d'être tombé dans le tout diesel un peu
la solution unique on a quand même un
peu le sentiment que on retombe dans le
tout électrique simplement voilà on est
pragmatique aujourd'hui c'est à dire
l'industrie on a essayé on a porté nos
sujets la décision a été prise dans un
moment où on voyait de façon très
explicite tous les risques inhérents ou
tout électrique puisque malheureusement
bon voilà la guerre en Ukraine était
déjà engagée on avait des explosions des
prix des matières premières sur lequel
on a aucune prise puisqu'on est
totalement dépendant qui a des
conséquences beaucoup plus lourdes
encore pour le prix d'un véhicule
électrique qu'un véhicule thermique
puisque il y a beaucoup beaucoup plus
justement de matériaux critiques au
travers de la batterie la batterie c'est
40% du prix mais voilà la décision a été
prise nous on est les industriels il y a
un moment on a besoin de Cape on a
besoin de visibilité il y a des
investissements considérables qui ont
été engagés alors encore une fois on
n'est pas contre du tout l'électrique
pour certains usages alors vous avez des
témoignages qui ne sont pas que positifs
mais on a quand même pas mal de
témoignages assez positifs de l'usage
d'un véhicule électrique encore une fois
en fonction des types d'usage que l'on a
mais c'est vrai que pour des personnes
qui ont les moyens de se recharger
d'ailleurs chez soi quand même pas très
cher
l'électrique à domicile notamment si on
va vers des bornes de recharge
intelligentes qui permettent notamment
de d'utiliser les tarifs creuses de la
nuit ça c'est quand même intéressant il
y a pas besoin de patience
station-service de ce côté-là quand on a
un usage voilà plutôt régulier qui
permet de se rendre que on a des
parcours qui ne sont pas trop longs et
quand même le de conduite de
l'électrique les retours qu'on a sont
plutôt positifs de ce côté là par contre
effectivement en faire la solution
unique pour nous c'est un sujet
simplement voilà aujourd'hui c'est parti
et ce que je pense aujourd'hui c'est que
avant tout maintenant que c'est parti
maintenant que les investissements sont
engagés et vous avez vu on a quand même
réussi à attirer en France à certains
d'investissements massifs sur les
batteries notamment dans les hauts de
France en particulier aujourd'hui je
dirais que d'un certain côté maintenant
faut qu'on réussisse et donc pour nous
notre message vis-à-vis des pouvoirs
publics vous avez décidé donc cette
trajectoire nous honnêtement côté
industrie
faire des véhicules électriques on sait
faire il n'y a pas de difficulté c'est
même plus simple d'un certain côté il y
a l'enjeu de la batterie mais là dessus
il y a quand même disons aujourd'hui des
très grands projets qui sont en cours la
difficulté pour nous c'est un d'avoir
des infrastructures de recharge parce
que c'est quand même un sujet parce
qu'effectivement dès qu'on a des usages
avec de l'itinérance sur des grands
trajets pour le moment on est très très
loin du confort et de la flexibilité
qu'on peut avoir avec les véhicules
thermiques c'est une évidence donc il
faut qu'on se rapproche quand même de ça
donc ça c'est quand même un des points
importants et puis il y a des questions
de prix qui va falloir et notamment le
fait qu'on ait cette crise de l'énergie
avec honnêtement aujourd'hui le prix de
l'électricité est deux fois plus
important au moins en Europe que et
notamment en France qu'on l'a aux
États-Unis qu'on l'a en Chine et une des
grandes difficultés aujourd'hui c'est
que on voit bien l'augmentation mais
spectaculaire des importations de
véhicules chinois qui ont 10 ans
d'avance sur la chaîne de valeur de
l'électrique donc nous on dit voilà on
est embarqué là-dedans ça a été une
décision et encore une fois
fondamentalement on n'a pas le choix que
de prendre des mesures pour réduire
effectivement les émissions de CO2 mais
surtout créons les conditions pour qu'on
soit capable effectivement de réussir à
la fois que on préserve notre industrie
et pour ça on a besoin des règles du jeu
un peu plus équitable que ce qui nous
semble être le cas aujourd'hui et
d'autre part que on crée les conditions
d'acceptabilité pour les consommateurs
parce que aujourd'hui effectivement
on a encore beaucoup beaucoup de
questions à régler pour que ça permette
au plus grand nombre de gens d'avoir
accès à du véhicule électrique donc
voilà moi ce que je peux dire je dirais
globalement là-dessus donc on est en
situation nous soyons honnêtes un peu
inversés aujourd'hui c'est à dire voilà
c'est engagé faut réussir voilà mais ça
ne veut pas du tout dire qu'on adhère
pleinement au choix qui a été fait mais
il a été fait et donc notre
responsabilité c'est d'y répondre
merci je pourrais ajouter simplement
mais ça n'enlève rien à ce que ce qu'il
y a déjà été dit par Marc morturé sur le
fait que nous sommes tout à fait
favorable à la diversité technologique
pour tirer parti de l'ensemble des
énergies qui sont disponibles y compris
les énergies liquides des carbonées mais
le véhicule électrique a quand même un
vrai avantage par rapport au véhicules
thermiques c'est son rendement son
efficacité avec un rendement d'environ
90% par rapport à l'autorisation
thermique qui est de l'ordre de 35% au
mieux ce qui signifie que pour une unité
d'énergie consommée et ben un véhicule
électrique va transformer cette énergie
pour répondre aux besoins du véhicule à
hauteur de 90% ce qui veut dire que eau
global si on raisonne en
approvisionnement énergétique au niveau
français plus on bascule vers
l'électrification du transport routier
moi on consomme d'énergie au global et
ça ça peut aussi être intéressant du
point de vue la facture énergétique
consommée ne restitue que 0,90
90% de l'énergie du électrique est
utilisé pour l'avancement du véhicule à
l'inverse de moteur thermique qui un
moteur thermique le reste étant le reste
échappe en chaleur voilà le carburant
liquide en soi la motorisation diesel ou
essence a fait beaucoup de progrès mais
néanmoins le rendement énergétique d'un
moteur thermique c'est autour de 30%.
c'est à dire il y a qu'un tiers de
l'énergie initiale qu'il y a dans le
carburant qui sert à faire rouler le
véhicule alors que quand on a de
l'électricité dans la batterie 90% en
fait sert voilà donc il y a
effectivement sur un terme de bilan
énergétique c'est intéressant j'ai des
tableaux à nous confier oui bien sûr
le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général Monsieur le Directeur
Technique d'abord merci d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation c'est pas le cas de
tout le monde certains grands
constructeurs vont vous suivre et on les
en remercie d'autres pour le moment font
la sourde oreille alors on mesure bien
qu'il y a un débat avec un débat
compliqué et on mesure aussi la
difficulté qu'il y a parfois à
s'exprimer quand comme vous on doit
tenir compte d'une certaine diversité de
point de vue et vous l'avez très bien
dit de choix qui ont déjà été faits bon
alors dans ce que j'entends quand même
plusieurs points sur lesquels je
voudrais qu'on essaie de revenir vous
nous dites on est interrogatif pour
certains usages
alors est-ce qu'on est dans le débat qui
consiste à dire par exemple comme le
président l'a très bien dit à l'instant
pour des flottes de taxi pour des
captives pour par exemple la filière des
travaux publics
pour
certains éléments de la filière agricole
ou encore
voilà bon enfin sur un certain nombre de
pour le transport routier voilà ce que
je voulais dire dans ces cas-là
il faut réfléchir à rester sur un moteur
thermique est-ce que c'est ça où est-ce
que c'est de nous dire fondamentalement
c'est un choix qu'on a un petit peu subi
modulo ce que vous voulez nous dire sur
quand le rendement
et si on peut ébrécher ce dogme en 2026
on y sera favorable parce que je vous ai
aussi entendu nous dire on s'est
longtemps battus pour garder la
diversité technologique voilà mais quel
est le débat est-ce que c'est des usages
singuliers pour lesquels il faudra
préserver le moteur thermique ou est-ce
que c'est nous dire même sur le choix
global pour la véhicule particulier si
on peut revenir sur les outils
électriques on est prêt à le faire c'est
ma première question
alors moi d'abord je reviendrai sur le
fait que on fait tout ça pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique et ça
faut pas qu'on l'oublie parce que c'est
vraiment la ligne directrice et
là-dessus évidemment le conteste pas du
tout ça fait partie de notre
responsabilité de contribuer fortement
aux objectifs de l'accord de Paris de
réduire les émissions de CO2 donc pour
répondre à votre question sur les usages
on est là encore une fois plutôt
pragmatique c'est à dire que pour des
usages qui nécessitent des batteries
très importantes
ça peut se poser la question de savoir
s'il y a pas des alternatives qui ont
plus de sens parce que encore une fois
une très grosse batterie c'est beaucoup
de matériaux critiques c'est beaucoup
d'émissions de CO2 pour la fabrication
de la batterie donc on est toujours un
quand on est dans le basculement vers
l'électrique le bilan global dans bien
des cas et tout à fait favorable à
l'électrique mais il faut savoir que la
partie fabrication du véhicule pour
l'électrique et mais beaucoup plus de
CO2 et simplement comme il y en a
beaucoup moins sur toute la partie usage
au total le bilan est favorable mais du
coup plus on est dans des usages où il
va falloir une très grosse batterie
parce qu'on a des usages intensifs
et que on ne peut pas par rapport à
certains métiers surchargé en cours de
journée admettons par exemple quand on
est très grouleurs et que on peut pas se
permettre de perdre une heure ou deux
heures pour se recharger en cours de
journée voilà typiquement on est obligé
d'avoir des grosses batteries bon donc
notre sujet il est plus nous ce qu'on
veut c'est travailler en analyse de
cycle de vie de façon rationnelle de
façon posée et ensuite
cet objectif là aujourd'hui ce qu'on
trouve un peu dommage c'est que le
contenu carbone de l'électricité n'est
pas tellement pris en compte dans la
localisation des investissements par
exemple on fabrique à beaucoup de
batterie en Pologne en gris ou le
contenu carbone de l'électricité est
très élevé donc ça nous paraît pas très
cohérent et c'est ça qu'on trouve
dommage c'est que il est pas cette
cohérence d'ensemble donc du coup les
usages encore une fois c'est pas pour
vous dire explicitement mais à chaque
fois par rapport
aux besoins de l'utilisateur il y a des
cas où le basculement vers l'électrique
paraît disons tout à fait compatible et
même qui peut être très positif et dans
d'autres cas c'est très compliqué parce
que on n'aura pas du tout la même
flexibilité et parce que effectivement
ça peut conduire à des fois des tailles
de batterie du coup un poids d'ailleurs
extrêmement important qui paraît pas
forcément très souhaitable
indépendamment du coup et de tout ça
rien que même en termes de financer ou
de Global donc voilà notre réponse elle
est un peu froide au sens je dirais
d'essayer d'avoir une approche
relativement
disons orienté voilà de ne pas oublier
que l'objectif de tout ça c'est pas un
choix idéologique dans tel ou telle
technologie c'est réduire les émissions
de CO2 le plus possible et c'est là où
on considère quand même que le débat
pour avoir des carburants par carbone
peut avoir sa place notamment pour
l'ensemble du parc parce que c'est on va
avoir encore pendant longtemps un parc
de véhicules thermiques de toute façon
voilà donc je sais pas si tu veux
compléter sur peut-être de revenir sur
les différentes catégories de véhicules
ou effectivement alors il y a deux il y
a deux choses il y a d'une part l'aspect
un peu technique on a des véhicules
comme les véhicules utilitaires léger
pour lesquels l'électrification
lorsqu'on était tout petit véhicule peut
avoir du sens parce qu'on va transporter
des marchandises mais en masse
relativement limité et donc on a des on
a une offre de véhicules qui est tout à
fait adaptée lorsque on va augmenter la
taille du véhicule
utilitaire pour du transport de
marchandises en volume un peu plus
important là on va avoir des difficultés
à loger suffisamment de batterie pour
que on puisse répondre aux besoins des
artisans qui vont et donc dans ce cas de
figure effectivement on a une forme de
blocage technologique qui nous conduit à
imaginer d'autres types de solutions et
l'autre solution qu'on a à l'esprit
c'est de utiliser l'hydrogène dans une
pile à combustible à hydrogène pour
proposer ces solutions certes c'est
encore cher on va essayer de
démocratiser cette solution
technologique et en particulier dans les
véhicules utilitaires les gestion la
question du transport routier de
marchandises pour des véhicules des
camions un peu plus lourds on a une
série d'acteurs au niveau européen qui
se sont quand même très fortement
engagés également à électrifier leur
gamme y compris des véhicules de 44
tonnes donc là on a un petit peu plus de
place pour le G des batteries et ils
imaginent à l'horizon 2040 être dans
ils imaginent à l'horizon de 2040 avoir
une proportion alors c'est assez
variable mais pour ceux qui sont les
plus ambitieux jusqu'à
80% de véhicules électriques dans
l'organe évidemment l'électrique
apparaîtra plus dans les camions de
livraison urbaine et matériaux urbaine
que dans le que dans le long routier et
une et 20% qui serait plutôt des camions
donc
longue distance utilisant de l'hydrogène
dans une pile à combustible de
l'hydrogène sous forme d'hydrogène
combustion c'est-à-dire que c'est le
moteur thermique va être préservé on va
utiliser de l'hydrogène directement dans
le moteur à combustion et puis également
des solutions qui vont être basées sur
des carburant liquides décarbonés donc
qu'on connaît type
huile végétale hydrotraités ou carburant
de synthèse
oui merci de ces éléments
vous voyez vraiment quand même les
transporteurs avoir une flotte avec
trois modes de propulsion ou enfin trois
types d'énergie
de l'hybride via la pile à combustible
de l'électrique et puis des carburants
type biocarburant
c'est quand même pas si évident que ça
point 2 quand même là j'imagine que vous
avez des discussions avec non seulement
les raffineurs mais en tout cas les
distributeurs parce que derrière les
choix technologiques pour la gamme
automobile au sens large
ce profil la question de maintien ou pas
de réseau de distribution nous avons
entendu dans cette mission le président
total qui nous a dit que dans certains
pays il vendait ses réseaux de
distribution parce qu'il considérait que
c'était plus l'avenir donc du coup
qu'elle peut être l'impact parce que
derrière les choix monsieur mordu la dit
tout à l'heure il y a des choix
technologiques mais après il faut aussi
qu'il y ait un système de distribution
donc est-ce que tout ça c'est bien
qu'elle est et puis deuxièmement sur sur
l'hydrogène merci de l'avoir d'être
vous-même
j'entends aussi il y a l'hydrogène il y
a l'hybride rechargeable qui aurait une
deuxième jeunesse avec alors ou des
cartes biocarburants ou des fuel bon
mais là aussi
on peut critiquer le choix d'aller très
largement vers l'électrique à l'inverse
on finit par s'interroger est-ce que
cette diversité est possible dernier
point quand même et j'arrêterai là
comment vous faites dans le reste du
monde
parce que vous produisez pas pour
l'Europe en tout cas vos mendons ne
produisent pas pour l'Europe et est-ce
que ce choix-là peut être possible
c'est-à-dire d'avoir un choix un peu
monocentré disons plutôt très centré sur
électrique et
reste du monde de continuer à avoir un
système de propulsion qui est le
thermique
merci beaucoup pour tous ces questions
qui sont tout à fait pertinentes et qui
correspondent aussi à des questions
qu'on se pose alors la question des
transporteurs pour le transport routier
oui bien entendu un on a beaucoup de
d'échanges avec eux et oui c'est
compliqué à ce stade oui c'est compliqué
c'est à dire aujourd'hui de notre
responsabilité c'est moins de développer
l'offre déjà parce que c'est quand même
le premier sujet donc développer l'offre
de véhicules électriques il commence à y
en avoir le salon sur du trans
d'ailleurs qui est l'occasion à Lyon
tous les deux ans c'est assez
spectaculaire de voir les
investissements qui sont faits dans des
solutions électriques à batterie ou
hydrogène en alternative évidemment à
des camions au gaz biogaz et puis il y a
donc HBO
Bessan voilà mais à chaque fois qui ont
des avantages des inconvénients il y a
des solutions francophones 16 pour des
transporteurs qui circulent sur
l'ensemble de l'Europe il y a plein de
questions et oui bien entendu on est au
début pour les transports transports
routiers pour les poids lourds pour les
véhicules industriels on est encore au
début on a cette proposition qui est sur
la table maintenant du Conseil européen
et du Parlement européen qui a pas
encore été discuté tu vas être discuté
mais ça pousse plein de questions parce
qu'effectivement il y a des contraintes
opérationnelles qui sont à prendre en
compte et pour le coup on parlait des
usages pour les particuliers mais
évidemment pour les professionnels c'est
évidemment un champ de contraintes qui
est très important donc
c'est effectivement aujourd'hui
des échanges pour voir quel type de
trajectoire peut être proposé qu'elle
peut être l'offre qui va être proposée
il y aura sûrement dans les périodes de
transition une diversité de solutions
technologiques inévitablement et ça
effectivement ça peut être une
contrainte pour certains ça peut être
aussi une opportunité pour d'autres mais
on aura cette cet aspect là la question
un peu que vous avez évoqué du biseau
c'est-à-dire quand on va se retrouver
éventuellement vers de moins en moins
par exemple de véhicules thermiques sur
l'avenir service et autres
personnellement je pense c'est un sujet
qu'on n'a pas encore beaucoup abordé qui
va pas arriver à très court terme parce
qu'encore une fois le le
thermique va rester très dominant
pendant encore longtemps vu le rythme de
remplacement de toute façon mais la
question elle devra se poser parce que
tout ça va pas être complètement
linéaire il y a un moment où ça posera
effectivement des questions et on l'a
pas encore complètement traitées 2035
n'est pas tenable ce que vous voulez
dire non non c'est des véhicules neufs
mais en 2035 on aura encore au niveau du
parc beaucoup de véhicules thermiques de
toute façon donc c'est pour ça que la
question effectivement se posera mais
elle se pose pas pour le moment encore
je pensais pas pour encore un certain
temps après le débat sur mais on peut
pas le tout électrique comme solution
unique c'est pas très bon mais en même
temps le fait de garder plein de
solutions technologiques différentes
c'est pas viable oui vous avez raison
aussi simplement ce qu'on pense c'est
que c'est quand même aux industriels le
plus possible possible de tester d'aller
le plus loin possible pour essayer de
trouver les meilleures solutions parce
que on est convaincu qu'on n'est pas du
tout au bout des innovations qui devront
être faites pour aller vers la
neutralité carbone on espère d'ailleurs
que dans le domaine des batteries on a
encore beaucoup de progrès l'hydrogène
il peut y avoir beaucoup de progrès les
if you peut-être voilà enfin il y a on
est dans un monde où en même temps comme
il y a une forte focalisation il y a
quand même beaucoup d'efforts beaucoup
d'investissements qui sont faits et donc
on espère bien qu'il va y avoir encore
pas mal d'innovation et donc pour nous
oui il y a un moment où il faut choisir
on peut pas effectivement garder
éternellement toutes les solutions
technologiques par contre ça nous paraît
plutôt de la responsabilité des
industriels par rapport à des
contraintes et des échéances qui sont
fixées et c'est là où on a un peu plus
de difficultés sur la façon dont la
réglementation européenne a été écrite
mais que à ce stade on considère Nicolas
Le Bigot a évoqué tout à l'heure bon
voilà par exemple l'hydrogène en moteur
thermique quoi injection voilà
typiquement ça fait partie des choses
qui sont regardées par les constructeurs
les if you bah voilà beaucoup de
constructeurs vérifient que leur
véhicule sont compatibles avec
potentiellement desifles et ça c'est
quand même intéressant de savoir si ça
peut être compatible voilà il y a
beaucoup de choses encore qui vont
avancer donc c'est un peu dans cet
équilibre et le reste du monde alors le
reste du monde d'abord c'est très clair
on a dans le reste du monde beaucoup un
constructeur qui reste sur deux pieds
thermiques électrique parce que
l'électrique commence à se développer
partout il faut être clair et c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle les Américains
qui étaient très en retard maintenant
mettre le pied sur l'accélérateur vers
l'électrique mais par contre ils sont
pas dans une décision de solution unique
il y a bien les deux pieds après pour
l'avenir de notre propre industrie très
honnêtement on a entendu certains de
dire mais c'est pas grave on continuera
à fabriquer en Europe du termine pour
l'export ça ça nous laisse un peu
sceptique au regard d'une industrie qui
est totalement mondialisée et où assez
logiquement les industriels investiront
dans le thermique là où il y a de
l'avenir pour le thermique donc c'est
très clair que on a de très grandes
inquiétudes et ce plus que des
inquiétudes sur le désengagement des
acteurs progressivement évidemment du
thermique en France c'est quand même à
peu près 50 000 personnes qui
progressivement ben voilà auront de
moins en moins de travail c'est une
certitude par rapport à ça mais par
contre dans le reste du monde oui c'est
clair que les technologies vont
continuer à se développer aussi dans le
thermique même si il y a une
accélération de l'électrique donc pas
mal de régions du monde
oui merci vous avez de la Marne vous
avez réparu
en partie à mes inquiétudes mais vous
manquerez d'autres moi quand j'avais vu
que la filière automobile partait tous
azimut allez on investit tous les
électriques 2035 aux ordres bon je me
suis dit c'est curieux quand même et ça
me paraît bon et vous venez de me
confirmer que effectivement vous êtes
dans une logique à pas mettre tous vos
œufs dans le même panier ça franchement
ça me rassure
mais par contre vous le dites bien
véhicule chinois dix ans d'avance quoi
alors nous faire des aides pour nos pour
les la population française qu'elle se
mettait électrique pour acheter du VIH
culture chinois c'est pas notre tasse de
thé et une autre chose qui est qui me
préoccupe dans tout cela parce que c'est
un combat titanex et vous l'avez dit
c'est contre le réchauffement climatique
sauf que quand on achète un véhicule
thermique on vend un véhicule diesel ou
à essence et le véhicule il est déjà
bien usé qu'est-ce qu'il va il va dans
le Sud après il va en Afrique du Nord et
puis après il descend et puis il
continue à polluer la planète pendant
des lustres quoi votre nom à 200000 km
que vous avez vendu pour acheter un
moteur beaucoup plus enfin une voiture
plus performante vous la retrouvez 10-15
ans après
dans d'autres pays où elle
a un million de kilomètres quoi donc
quand on fait le bilan globalement
mondial qu'est-ce qu'on a gagné dans
tout ça donc soyons c'est pour je suis
rassuré que vous continuez à travailler
dans la filière thermique et tant mieux
si on arrive à trouver des carburants
qui soient plus neutres en carbone et
qui peuvent aller adapter les moteurs
thermiques parce que contenu de
l'évolution des choses ça paraît
vraiment rassurant ça est-ce que vous
pensez que cette adaptation est vraiment
réaliste et devrait permettre est-ce
qu'on puisse garder nos voitures
thermiques ce qui évite qu'elle soit
continue à polluer plus mais qui
marcherait ces voitures thermiques avec
des carburants beaucoup plus neutres en
carbone sans atteindre la neutralité 0
avec l'objectif de l'atteindre mais pas
forcément dans des délais irréalistes
quoi est-ce que c'est vraiment
compatible
alors
peut-être par rapport aux
bonus et aux importations chinoises
d'abord un petit point là dessus nous
vous savez on a on a plaidé je dirais à
l'image de ce qu'on fait des américains
avec l'IRA américain qui très
explicitement
réserve finalement les soutiens aux
productions aux États-Unis ou dans les
pays avec lequel il signe un certain
nombre d'accord nous on a dit mais faut
pas que l'Europe soit un peu l'idiot du
village quoi dans le dans la scène
internationale parce que honnêtement les
chinois ils ont bénéficié de subvention
absolument considérables ils ont un
marché intérieur absolument considérable
et c'est vrai qu'ils ont des moyens
absolument considérables et si quand je
dis on ne se protège pas c'est même pas
de faire du protectionnisme mais
simplement d'avoir des conditions
équitables
ça ira pas donc de ce côté là les
réflexions actuelles du gouvernement
d'aller sur un bonus véhicule électrique
qui
est plutôt réservé à des productions
européennes on a poussé plutôt ça par
contre ce qui nous inquiète un peu c'est
si c'est pas explicitement assumé et
qu'on est dans des logiques parce que
c'est ce qu'on comprend un peu de
vouloir fixer des critères objectifs sur
l'empreinte CO2 sur des aspects de
matière recyclées etc ce qu'on craint
c'est qu'il y a tellement de moyens de
calculer d'avoir des contrats d'énergie
verte qu'on peut présenter etc c'est que
on finisse par une usine à gaz et que ça
ne répond pas l'objectif qui a été fixé
d'essayer de concentrer voilà les moyens
plus dipli plutôt pour voilà privilégier
donc ça ça nous paraît important
d'assumer d'une façon d'une autre
nécessité d'avoir une certaine
préférence européenne pour aujourd'hui
réussir à ce que notre industrie se
reconvertissent
sans être immédiatement challenger par
des véhicules
venant de Chine à des prix effectivement
qui sont alors bien sûr tout en ayant
cette préoccupation d'offrir aux
consommateurs
évidemment les prix mais c'est un point
délicat mais pour nous qui est essentiel
faut voir quand même c'est spectaculaire
la progression des importations
chinoises c'est spectaculaire donc et
encore en ce début d'année par rapport à
2022 ça continue à progresser fortement
donc on a alerté depuis pas mal de temps
sur ce risque là Jean-Dominique Sénart
d'ailleurs président de Renaud qui était
avant chez Michelin toujours beaucoup
alerté parce qu'il a vu ça avant dans le
domaine des pneus donc c'est un vrai
sujet pour nous on pense que si on ne
change pas fortement la donne pour que
on trouve au niveau de l'Europe les
moyens de de donner le temps de
construire une industrie forte dans
toutes ces nouvelles chaînes de valeurs
de l'électrique qu'on va voir énormément
de difficultés donc ça c'était un peu
sur le premier point sur bonus après
vous aviez
garder le thermique votre question
pardon et ces véhicules thermiques et en
fait repartent dans d'autres pays et
j'ai mis alors petite question
supplémentaire c'est l'avenir d'hybride
parce qu'on nous a dit à un moment
l'hybride c'est très bien beaucoup avoir
acheté une d'ailleurs et maintenant on
nous dit Oh l'hybride c'est lourd ça
consomme etc est-ce que justement il y a
pas un dans ce délai un temps pour
l'hybride au biocarburant en attendant
de passer à des carburants neutres etc
quoi il y a quand même de la place dans
ces années là pour amortir un véhicule
d'ici 10 15 20 ans on ira effectivement
avec l'objectif de neutralité carbone
dans nos carburants mais actuellement il
y a ces possibilités pourquoi les
constructeurs ne sont pas engagés dans
cette voie là puisque quand on achète
une véhicule hybride français à
l'essence on nous dit pas de
bio-carburant moi je vous le garantis
pas surtout pas n'allez pas en mettre
là-dedans on nous dit que c'est pas
compatible il faudrait savoir un petit
peu s'il y a une volonté ou pas
d'utiliser les Biocar Bures en attendant
des carburants plus neutres bien entendu
alors peut-être avant d'en venir à la
question de l'hybride répondre à votre
question précédente sur l'export de
véhicule c'est vous avez raison il y a
une fuite des véhicules relativement
âgée du territoire européen vers
l'Afrique en particulier mais aussi au
sein même de l'Union européenne nos
véhicules vont plutôt avoir tendance à
finir leur vie dans les pays dans les
pays de l'est parce que de toute façon
dans ces pays-là effectivement les PIB
fait que ils ont plus de difficultés
qu'ailleurs à acheter des véhicules
neufs donc ils consomment les véhicules
qui sont de deuxième troisième
quatrièmement des pays d'Europe de
l'Ouest et ça renforce la nécessité de
travailler sur toutes les solutions qui
permettent de décarboner les énergies
liquides qui vont être consommées par
ces véhicules à l'échelle européenne
parce qu'on sait bien que dans ces
pays-là l'électrification va sans doute
prendre plus plus se fera plus lentement
qu'ailleurs parce que ça va nécessiter
des investissements sur les
infrastructures de distribution
d'électricité des infrastructures tant
de production d'électricité propre et de
distribution on le voit bien c'est des
investissements qui sont relativement
colossaux ça va prendre plus de temps et
donc de ce fait là bah il est utile
d'essayer d'aller chercher toutes les
solutions de drcarbonation des véhicules
thermiques avec les agro les bio avancés
les carburants de synthèse etc etc donc
et puis c'est aussi vrai dans la mesure
où nous-même constructeurs automobiles
dans un esprit déco conception on va
avoir tendance à essayer de faire en
sorte que ces véhicules qui coûtent
quand même de plus en plus cher au vu
des des crises qu'on subit sur la hausse
des prix des matériaux aller faire durer
le plus longtemps possible et à les
remettre à jour au cours de leur vie au
fil de leurs propriétaires successifs
donc du coup et ça c'est très positif
parce que ça permet de ne pas produire
un autre véhicule neuf qui lui aura
aussi un impact on emprunte carbone du
fait de sa production donc on est bien
dans une logique d'économie circulaire
et d'économie de fonctionnalités
deuxième deuxième élément sur l'hybride
sur l'hybride alors plusieurs
problématiques sur l'hybride d'une part
on s'est aperçu que les plus grosses
utilisateurs de véhicules hybrides
rechargeables étaient les flottes de
véhicules d'entreprise or les flottes de
véhicules d'entreprise
enfin les entreprises n'ont pas
forcément mis à disposition de leurs
salariés tous les moyens de correctement
utiliser ces véhicules en les
rechargeant et à l'inverse elles ont
donné aux salariés des cartes carburants
pour aller faire le plein à la pompe à
essence et ce qui fait que finalement au
global ils étaient très peu utilisés en
mode 100% électrique et aujourd'hui la
Commission européenne nous dit qu'elle
va utiliser les données d'usage réel de
ces véhicules pour les homologuer au
niveau de leurs performances CO2 ce qui
veut dire qu'on va retenir alors usage
principalement en mode thermique pour
définir la valeur CO2 alors
qu'aujourd'hui dans l'homologation on
retient que ce véhicule là est utilisé à
75% du temps en mode 100% électrique ce
qui veut dire que si effectivement on
met ça en œuvre
l'intérêt CO2 pour le constructeur
automobile n'est plus et donc par
rapport à ces objectifs qui consiste à
répondre à la réglementation de CO2 il y
a de moins en moins d'intérêt mais vous
avez raison bien entendu lorsque ce
véhicule utilise un carburant des
carboné qui soit agissent des thanhan à
hauteur de 10%, ce qui est le carburant
de référence au niveau européen ou
peut-être même d'un neuvain pourquoi pas
à l'avenir ça déclaronne avec du
carburant de synthèse aussi interne
pourquoi pas bien entendu sur la
question du flex c'est un autre sujet
sur lequel on peut avoir une un débat
assez spécifique que je peux je peux je
peux peut-être en profiter tout de suite
le le flexuel oui un hybride
rechargeable utilisant un carburant E85
bah oui c'est finalement la somme des
des meilleurs performances bien entendu
cependant il faut avoir à l'esprit que
c'est des développements c'est développé
nécessaire de plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'euros pour développer un
moteur flex fuel et à ce stade
malheureusement ce carburant en 85 et
surtout un carburant franco-français et
donc d'avoir de la d'imaginer des
développements qui nous pourraient être
rentabilisés que sur le marché français
c'est en soi pas suffisant pour pousser
nos constructeurs à de nouveau
proposer dans leur catalogue des
véhicules flexfuel je dis de nouveau
parce que ils ont déjà joué le jeu à
l'époque en 2006 si je me souviens bien
le gouvernement avait sollicité les
constructeurs automobiles à proposer des
versions flexfuel de leur dans l'organe
ce qu'ils ont fait et il s'est avéré que
c'était plutôt un échec commercial alors
même si c'est un peu marché en France
mais au global ça n'a pas permis de
rentabiliser les investissements et donc
on est un peu toujours dans ce même cas
de figure d'un carburant qui
avec l'équipe
alors avec les kits ça marche très bien
enfin ça marche très bien nous on n'est
pas très favorable au kit parce que en
dehors du kit le véhicule n'a pas été
homologué pour recevoir ce carburant il
y a des contraintes sur les matériaux il
y a des contraintes sur les risques de
d'impact sur la dépollution du véhicule
avec des émissions qui pourraient être
un peu plus élevées mais effectivement
on constate que il y a des poses de kit
qui sont relativement nombreuses du fait
sans doute d'un intérêt économique pour
le pour le consommateur et
essentiellement
et que et écologique
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est quand même le
véhicule me semble-t-il mais je connais
pas tout mais c'est le véhicule le moins
polluant c'est quand même celui-là si
vous faites un hybride
à E85
il bénéficie et Marc mortueux l'a dit
d'une petite batterie donc avec un
impact en empreinte carbone de
production de la batterie réduite et de
et de l'intérêt en matière de
décarbonation du carburant lui-même mais
ça n'enlève rien à ce que je viens de
dire sur les coûts de développement qui
ne seraient que très peu rentabilisé
puisque centré essentiellement sur le
marché français et puis ça a déjà été
dit également les constructeurs ne
tirent aucun avantage au regard de la
réponse à la réglementation sur les
émissions de CO2 à utiliser un carburant
E85
monsieur rapporteur voulait rebondir
après je passerai pas à Madame Gosselin
vous allez aborder le soutien
des États notamment
s'agissant des
USA comme de la Chine et filigrane à ce
que fait l'Union européenne et ce que ce
que fait la France
mais alors est-ce que vous pouvez aller
plus loin là-dessus parce qu'on regarde
tous lira on s'interroge on voit
l'arrivée des productions notamment
chinoise japonaise bon qu'est-ce que
vous souhaiteriez que les pouvoirs
publics étudient comme mesure qui
seraient favorables à la fois à la
transition environnementale et au
maintien des emplois de la filière et
puis d'ailleurs s'agissant de la filière
vous pouvez nous dire quand même quel
est l'impact du passage de l'électrique
alors
pour nous lira Lyra américain
a le gros avantage d'être un dispositif
très pragmatique assez simple mettent en
place et qui du coup est assez efficace
aujourd'hui pour déclencher les
décisions d'investissement par toute une
série d'acteurs
en tant que tel côté automobile
c'est pas tellement les États-Unis qui
nous inquiètent malgré tout pour notre
avenir sur le marché européen parce que
globalement quand même pour l'essentiel
c'est quand même des investissements qui
vont être fait en Europe pour répondre
au marché européen par contre pour nous
lire américain c'est un bonne
occasion de se poser quand même beaucoup
de questions au niveau de l'Europe et
encore une fois dans un contexte
par exemple encore une fois les
importations de véhicules chinois qui
arrivent en Europe c'est 10% de droits
de douane c'est 27 et demi aux
États-Unis ils ont pris des dispositions
de nature assez différente voilà nous
notre problème en Europe c'est le cumule
de toute une série d'éléments qui ne
sont pas favorables
au-delà disons des structures un peu de
coups de compétitivité qui existe depuis
assez longtemps notre grande difficulté
et aujourd'hui c'est le coût de
l'énergie qui est deux fois trois fois
plus élevé qu'ailleurs dans le monde et
ça c'est un vrai vrai sujet et c'est le
cumule des différentes contraintes et on
va vers une des carbonation presque
indépendamment de l'électrique qui va
nous amener à devoir utiliser de l'acier
des carbonée de l'aluminium des
carbonées et tout ça est très bien mais
ça coûte de l'argent et une des
difficultés que nous avons là-dedans
c'est que vous savez il y a un mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières qui
est mis en place qui sur le principe
nous paraît très bien sauf que pour une
industrie comme l'automobile comme c'est
un mécanisme qui ne couvre que les
matières premières et l'énergie qui va
être en compensation de la fin des
quotas gratuits pour ces secteurs là
on va avoir demain une situation où si
je veux fabriquer mes pièces en acier
par exemple en Europe je vais soit
acheter l'acier
plus cher un décarboné en Europe soit je
vais l'acheter à l'étranger en dehors de
l'Europe mais il va être soumis au
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières donc pour compenser et qu'il
est le même coup donc ça c'est bien sauf
que là où il y a un grand trou dans la
raquette c'est que du coup pour
l'automobile pour un donneur d'ordre il
va plutôt acheter non pas de l'acier
mais des pièces et des composants en
acier fabriqués à l'extérieur de
l'Europe
moins cher puisqu'ils qui ne seront pas
du tout soumis à ces problèmes de
décarbonation et autres et là par contre
ils échappent totalement aux mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières donc
pour nous c'est un mécanisme qui risque
de favoriser la délocalisation de toute
une série d'activités de sous-traitance
pour l'automobile voilà et à chaque fois
on cherche à faire des choses en soi
intéressante afin qu'ils sont
nécessaires sauf que on a des vrais
problèmes disons d'exécution et de
définition des périmètres qui font qu'on
a tout un cumule donc voilà nous nos
sujets très concrètement pour répondre à
votre question c'est on a évoqué le
bonus c'est vrai que ça c'est quand même
assez efficace d'essayer au travers de
ce genre d'instruments incitatif de
faire en sorte que on privilégie les
productions pas forcément françaises
mais en tout cas européenne
et qui quand même ont du sens parce
qu'on a de l'énergie qui est davantage
des carbonées quand même donc ça c'est
un point important il y a donc des
projets pas seulement de crédit d'impôt
en tout cas on a besoin et le
gouvernement le fait pour partie
effectivement d'apporter des soutiens
importants je dirais équivalents à ce
qu'ils peuvent être apportés au Canada
aux États-Unis dans les autres pays
européens etc pour attirer les
investissements donc sur certains sujets
on y arrive donc c'est bien et puis on a
quand même un problème général de niveau
de structure de charge parce qu'encore
une fois notre grand sujet on a un
groupe comme Renault par exemple qui a
décidé d'implanter finalement toute la
fabrication de ces véhicules électriques
dans le nord de la France c'est une
belle opportunité c'est une chance un
pour la France le vrai sujet pour nous
c'est ce que on va réussir à fabriquer
des véhicules électriques de qualité ça
je n'en doute pas un prix suffisamment
abordable pour le plus grand nombre de
façon à avoir des modèles qui vont se
vendre en volume puisque on est sur une
industrie volume donc toutes les mesures
qui permettent de réduire les coûts
sont très importants pour réussir cette
transition d'autant qu'il y a cette
concurrence qui est importante et qui
est quand même assez compétitive avec
des véhicules notamment chinois coréens
etc qui sont de qualité faut pas voilà
faut être clair aujourd'hui il y a il y
a des productions de qualité donc voilà
nous on a besoin vraiment de mesure je
dirais un petit peu exceptionnel dans
cette situation assez exceptionnelle
pour donner le temps à notre industrie
de devenir compétitive avec évidemment
beaucoup d'efforts de R&D en même temps
parce qu'on n'est pas au bout des
innovations comme je disais tout à
l'heure pour lequel effectivement faut
réussir et faut qu'on réussisse à créer
des écosystèmes les plus complets
possible parce que c'est bien d'avoir
des Gica Factory de batterie mais il
faut absolument qu'on crée tous les
maillons en amont pour fournir la
matière pour faire les composants les
plus actifs le cathode à note pour les
cellules etc donc c'est en train il y a
des briques qui sont en train d'arriver
il y a eu des annonces ces derniers
jours intéressants avec des
investissements importants qui sont
faits mais on a vraiment besoin et
notamment sur le sujet de l'énergie avec
la fin de la reine en 2025 c'est vrai
que plus on va vers électrique plus on
va quand même vers des process
électro-intensifs relativement électro
intensif c'est assez en tout cas c'est
pas on n'est pas sur des activités
électroniques mais on consomme de plus
en plus d'électricité pour fabriquer des
véhicules électriques donc c'est quand
même un enjeu très important pour nous
de savoir quelle va être l'avenir toutes
les discussions qu'il y a au niveau
européen donc c'est vraiment des des
points importants là dessus
de la Manche oui
vous parliez que c'était pas faute
d'avoir alerté longtemps mais on
pourrait être en adéquation avec les
objectifs de Paris et puis les
incitations assez politiques présentes
de nos gouvernements européens vous avez
dû donc faire le choix de l'industrie
automobile est quasiment uniquement
automobile donc est-ce que vous pourriez
me dire quels sont les comment le nombre
les années à peu près où vous avez été
obligé de faire ce choix drastique alors
même si c'est pas aussi simple que ça
mais quelle évolution à quel moment
vraiment il y a eu l'élan vers le tout
électrique et la deuxième chose vous
parliez du cycle de vie alors moi je
trouve et là je vous rejoins que parler
du cycle de vie c'est quand même
beaucoup moins
pipé les dés que de que de que de parler
que de la mode que de la voiture que de
la batterie la roue puisque tous tous
les tous les éléments rentrent en jeu et
quand vous disiez tout à l'heure que
vous parliez des véhicules quand ils
arrivent vous aviez des besoins de
pièces de matériaux décarbonées et là
vous payez une taxe et vous achetez les
les produits finis quasiment vous ne
payez plus la taxe ça fait partie aussi
de ce calcul du cycle de vie puisque
enfin voilà il y a tout un tas de
processus en Amérique vous avez l'air du
dire que c'est beaucoup plus pragmatique
qu'est-ce qui empêche en Europe d'avoir
cette pragmatisme qui permettrait
justement de border tout et non pas
d'avoir toujours le trou de souris dans
lequel s'engouffre vraiment le les
finalement les difficultés et sur
lesquelles on se fait on se fait souvent
est-ce que c'est moi mais un petit peu
blouser
je suis un peu
le Président je prolonge encore la
question de de ma collègue et ça
m'étonne pas qu'on avait le même point
en tête parce que vous avez plusieurs
fois effectivement et je vous en
remercie
aborder la question de réouvrir
le sujet de l'analyse en cycle de vie et
vous nous avez dit quelque part qui
avait une opportunité avec l'annonce
compliquée qui a été faite
d'un futur acte délégué de la Commission
et la possibilité effectivement de
donner une
souplesse pour les les carburants de
synthèse bon pour l'industrie automobile
donc vous me dites ça ouvre une approche
à nouveau en analyse de style de vie
alors ce combat là est-ce que
l'industrie automobile est prêt à le
mener quelles sont les prérequis pour
avoir une chance d'y arriver et
comment vous voyez cette
remise sur le devant de la scène de ça
et qu'est-ce que vous en attendez
surtout derrière en clair est-ce qu'on
peut mener ce combat est-ce que vous
êtes prêt à le faire et qu'elle peut
être le gain
si on est de cycle de vie est-ce que
vous pensez que du coup on va inverser
la priorité
de l'électrique vers des carburants de
synthèse
alors d'abord nous c'est en 2018 on a
fait un contrat de filière
qui a consacré non pas du tout le tout
électrique mais moi je me souviens en
Nicolas Hulot ministre des goji dit fin
des moteurs thermiques en 2040
et moi honnêtement quand je suis arrivé
à la PFA début 2018 je dis peut-être
peut-être
pas on était à 1% véhicule électrique
mais en tout cas si on veut aller vers
ça faut y aller maintenant faut démarrer
maintenant et c'est comme ça que on a
effectivement consacré collectivement au
niveau de l'ensemble la filière et sans
aucun état d'âme parce que tant qu'on
était au démarrage encore une fois notre
message c'est pas du tout de dire on est
contre l'électrique c'est très bien pour
toute une série d'usages c'est très bien
voilà et encore une fois on n'a pas le
choix c'est effectivement voilà et du
coup sans état d'âme et ça a été assez
utile ce contrat de filière parce que
globalement dans un débat où il y a des
gens qui croient des gens n'y croient
pas ça
un discours assez constant depuis 2018
sur le fait faut y aller faut y aller
faut y aller après entre temps ça s'est
accéléré de façon
voilà incroyable voilà au point d'aller
jusqu'au tout électrique qui n'était pas
en soi de notre position mais au moins
on n'a pas été pris de revers c'est ce
qui fait d'ailleurs qu'aujourd'hui on a
quand même pas mal d'entreprises qui ont
commencé à s'adapter à se développer etc
donc voilà globalement disons sur le
fond comment on a engagé ça j'avais pas
évoqué l'impact parce que vous nous avez
posé la question de l'impact de cette
transition vers électrique on a pas mal
d'études qui nous amènent à
anticiper 60000 70 000 pertes d'emplois
globalement on a l'effet volume encore
une fois on est loin d'avoir retrouvé
les niveaux d'avant on a l'effet
d'importation c'est à dire qu'une part
du marché ne sera plus accessible par
les les les acteurs européens à partir
du moment où il y a davantage
d'importations de produits qui viennent
qui viennent de loin et puis il y a tout
simplement l'impact que à partir du
moment où on va du thermique à
l'électrique on sait qu'un moteur
électrique c'est beaucoup plus simple
qu'un moteur thermique donc il y a moins
d'intensité en moins d'oeuvre voilà et
il y a beaucoup d'entreprises à
reconvertir à côté de ça on a des
créations d'emploi avec notamment les
giga Factory de batterie on a une usine
de pile à compultibles avec Symbio dans
l'électronique mais c'est clair que le
bilan global
il sera malgré tout défavorable en
termes de d'emploi au global dans le
domaine industriel après on peut voir
aussi que on va vers des écosystèmes
plus larges par exemple tout ce qui est
de la fabrication et surtout
l'installation des bornes de charges des
nouvelles éléments d'infrastructure ça
peut être des activités tout l'amour un
des gigafactories de batterie avec
notamment de l'électrochimie ça peut
être voilà et finalement nous on se bat
au moins déjà pour essayer de créer des
conditions pour recréer ces nouvelles
chaînes de valeur parce que de toute
façon c'est c'est nécessaire par rapport
à ça mais c'est douloureux soyons clairs
et on a en ce moment des débats
puisqu'on est en train de renégocier un
peu un contrat de filière on travaille
beaucoup aussi avec les organisations
syndicales avec l'ensemble un peu des
partenaires et on sait très bien qu'on a
une vraie question de soutenabilité de
la transition en cours on a besoin
d'efforts considérables de transition
finalement dans les compétences dont on
a besoin il y a beaucoup d'ailleurs de
grands projets qu'on a engagé par
rapport à ça on a plutôt la chance
d'être malgré tout dans un contexte qui
a beaucoup de besoins en compétences
dans plein de domaines automobile ou
hors automobiles donc il y a des
possibilités dans les territoires voilà
d'envisager des évolutions à condition
des anticiper le mieux possible donc
voilà on est dans cette démarche mais
c'est toujours eux et c'est compliqué
soyons clairs là-dessus après le
pragmatisme
enfin j'ai beaucoup travaillé au
fonctionnaire j'ai été beaucoup aussi
sur des affaires européennes l'Europe
est formidable simplement c'est complexe
c'est toujours des compromis et c'est
comme ça qu'on finit des fois par des
dispositions qui sont moins lisibles
parce que parce que les intérêts ne sont
pas tous alignés et par rapport à cette
question d'analyse de cycle de vie une
des questions nous qu'on a c'est qu'on a
un atout qui est quand même considérable
dans tout ça qui est qu'on a notre
électricité décarbonée on est vraiment
un des meilleurs avec un certain nombre
de pays d'Europe du Nord mais il y a des
pays qui sont pas très bons y compris
notre partenaire allemand qui
aujourd'hui est quand même dans une
et c'est très très compliqué de
valoriser dans les discussions qu'on a
au niveau européen le fait que oui ça a
quand même du sens d'implanter les
nouveaux processus qui sont très
consommateurs d'énergie dans un pays
comme la France parce que l'énergie est
décarbonée ça a du sens c'est très
compliqué c'est très compliqué à prendre
en compte et c'est ça aujourd'hui qui
est un peu difficile c'est que la
réglementation européenne telle qu'elle
est dans l'automobile finalement tiens
pas beaucoup compte de cette
localisation qui est quand même
intéressante en termes d'empreinte
carbone dans un pays plutôt de la France
que dans certains autres pays et c'est
là l'enjeu pour nous dans les
discussions à venir c'est qu'on intègre
bien l'ensemble de ces dimensions et
qu'on retrouve quand même l'intérêt que
la France a effectivement se dire s'il y
a un pays où ça vaut la peine de
localiser et je pense qu'honnêtement un
certain nombre des annonces récentes de
grands projets en France sont notamment
liés quand même à la la toux que
représente d'avoir de l'É lectricité des
carbonée alors évidemment pour nous un
des très grands enjeux c'est que toute
la les investissements à faire dans le
domaine de l'énergie
et notamment du nucléaire sont
extrêmement important pour nous c'est
clair que il faut que on est la garantie
d'avoir de l'électricité décarbonée en
quantité suffisante et Nicolas Le Bigot
évoquait tout à l'heure d'hydrogène on a
toute une série d'acteurs qui se sont
fortement investis dans l'automobile
vers l'hydrogène comme une alternative
aux batteries pour certains usages vous
verrez c'était l'antise tout à l'heure
mais on a également Renault on a Symbio
on a nos équipementsiers Michelin
faurcia qui sont beaucoup investibles la
sicomium donc il y a beaucoup
d'investissements qui ont été faits et
la difficulté qu'on rencontre à l'heure
actuelle c'est qu'on voit bien que pour
faire de l'hydrogène des carbonée faut
de l'énergie il faut beaucoup
d'électricité des carbonée et que comme
en ce moment on en manque bah on voit
bien qu'il y a un peu un ralentissement
dans cet élan qui était d'avoir une
alternative voilà et ça nous embête
parce que encore une fois il y a des
investissements qui ont été faits et
qu'on pense que c'est utile d'avoir
quand même un peu de diversité de
technologie là qui sont des technologies
0 émissions puisque c'est malgré tout
des véhicules électriques simplement
l'énergie utilisée c'est d'hydrogène qui
est transformé par la pile à combustible
en électricité quoi dans le véhicule
donc pour nous c'est un élément
important qui est complémentaire de la
batterie et pour le moment on voit bien
que les ambitions qui avaient été
affichées les investissements qui ont
été engagés on a un petit peu de
difficulté aujourd'hui parce que on
n'est pas sûr d'avoir suffisamment
d'hydrogène décarbonée
peut-être une petite question pour
terminer vous parliez de l'importance
des véhicules chinois qui qui arrivaient
chez nous je n'en connais pas je n'en
vois pas est-ce que sont les véhicules
de marque française fabriquées en Chine
ou est-ce que sont vraiment des
véhicules chinois qui viennent et j'ai
une deuxième question sur la R&D est-ce
que chacun travaille dans son coin ou
est-ce que au niveau européen par
exemple il y a des efforts communs qui a
des à votre niveau des moyens qui font
que on puisse progresser ensemble et
rapidement parce que qu'est-ce qui fait
que les chinois sont plus performants
que nous
et on sait qu'on est dans un temps
plutôt long pour essayer de bâtir une
une industrie qui permettrait de
fabriquer tous ces véhicules avec les
nouvelles technologies je parle pas que
de l'électricité
alors les marques chinoises vous en
connaissez peut-être pas encore beaucoup
parce que c'est assez récent mais je
peux vous dire que vous allez alors il y
a des marques type mg qui est une
ancienne marque britannique qui est
chinoise aujourd'hui complètement
chinoise
un modèle MG4 qui marche très bien en ce
moment qui est en train de se vendre on
a quand même le phénomène qu'avec les
pénuries de semi-conducteur
par exemple des loueurs n'arrivaient
plus à se fournir auprès de leurs
fournisseurs traditionnels et qui ont
acheté chinois et du coup les gens
commencent à s'habituer à avoir des
marques alors des marques
pour prendre les marques chinoises donc
effectivement mg et Waze biwy Dick et un
géant notamment un peu de tout le
domaine de l'énergie des batteries
hautes et qui est maintenant engagée
mais c'est un géant on va dire il y a
des marques chinoises c'est des géants
voilà que vous connaissez pas encore
mais vous allez connaître parce que
voilà et qui d'ailleurs sont en train de
reprendre sur le marché chinois départ
de marché considérable puisqu'on avait
des Volkswagen enfin pas tellement les
constructeurs français mais et là ils
sont en train
d'évacer assez largement sur
l'électrique les les constructeurs aussi
Nanto c'est vrai ils sont maintenant
montés en puissance ils ont des
véhicules de qualité et c'est vrai qu'il
y a des stratégies on l'a vu d'ailleurs
Mondial de l'auto biwei qui voilà ils
ont des stratégies de venir avec des
véhicules d'ailleurs de qualité
voilà donc c'est en train de venir moi
je peux vous dire c'était 4% de parts de
marché en moyenne en 2022 on est déjà à
6% sur les quatre premiers mois de
l'année 2023 c'est en train d'avancer
pas mal après ce qu'on sait pas très
bien c'est qu'elle va être la part
d'importation venant de Chine et la part
d'investissement fait par des chinois en
Europe il y a les deux voilà mais en
tout cas c'est une réalité et les après
les les
usines de batterie les c'est ATL bon qui
est pareil un acteur mais extrêmement
puissant voilà enfin il y a
effectivement beaucoup d'acteurs
émergents qui qui sont en train d'agir
et il y a par ailleurs quand on parle
d'importation chinoise par exemple il y
a Tesla un Tesla a beaucoup importé de
Chine vers l'Europe puis maintenant il
va y avoir l'usine à Berlin donc qui va
réduire sans doute les importations
chinoises mais on a aussi la Dacia
spring par exemple côté Renault qui est
fabriqué en Chine et on a un certain
nombre de marques occidentales qui aussi
commencent à fabriquer en Chine donc
c'est un ensemble
mais objectif c'est en train d'arriver
par contre c'est quand même des produits
où il y a un attachement à la marque et
c'est pour ça que je pense que tout
n'est pas perdu c'est à dire les marques
Peugeot Citroën Renault etc ça de la
valeur ça de la valeur parce que c'est
quand même pas un produit ordinaire donc
c'est vrai que si on arrive à avoir le
temps de constituer une chaîne de valeur
qui soit compétitive je veux dire cette
attachement à la marque et réel donc
il faut qu'on réussisse mon discours
n'est pas défaitiste au fait que mais il
faut que on se mobilise très fortement
et très rapidement tu voulais compléter
par quelque chose ou pas vous aviez une
deuxième oui sur la R&D sur la R&D alors
il y a des grands projets enfin de
notamment on a eu au niveau de l'Europe
donc les ipci les grands projets
européens
qu'on avait un peu appelé l'Airbus de la
batterie ou des choses comme ça qui ont
un volet industriel et un volet R&D
alors on est vite sur des sujets
compétitifs quand même donc c'est pas si
simple que ça par exemple aujourd'hui un
des grands aspects au-delà de
l'électrique c'est d'aller vers ce qu'on
appelle le software design des véhicules
qui sont d'abord définis un peu par des
architectures Software et des
calculateurs parce que on voit beaucoup
la transition énergétique mais dans le
même temps et c'est tout aussi
spectaculaire il y a une transition côté
digitale côté software
une voiture aujourd'hui c'est 100
millions de lignes de codes c'est-à-dire
7 à 8 fois plus que un Boeing 787 ou ça
va être un milliard en 2030 c'est-à-dire
tout est en train d'être développé avec
des fonctionnalités avec de
l'électronique partout on est en train
voilà le l'image du
smartphone à roulettes et sans doute
caricatural mais néanmoins et ça va être
sans doute l'élément de différenciation
le plus important et là pour le coup les
chinois sont très bons aussi ils sont
très avancés sur ces sujets là dire
c'est il y a la transition énergétique
mais si on va vers tout électrique ça
sera plus forcément un élément de
différenciation mais il y a aussi le
fait qu'on va de plus en plus vers des
objets de plus en plus intelligents de
plus en plus connectés de plus en plus
automatisé c'est aussi une dimension
très importante pour l'aérer des et puis
il y a tous les sujets d'économie
circulaire où il y a beaucoup de R&D
aussi qu'on est en train de faire sur
faut incorporer davantage de matières
recyclées et puis tout ce qui va être le
recyclage des batteries qui est un enjeu
considérable un sur lequel on a besoin
de reconstituer tous les maillons de la
chaîne de valeur en Europe et si
possible en partie en France et c'est là
où à Dunkerque qui a plusieurs briques
qui sont en train de se mettre en place
parce que si on n'y arrive pas tout
repartir en Chine faire tous les
matériaux finalement qui sont très
importants pour le futur si on n'a pas
toutes les étapes pour pouvoir les les
retraiter en Europe nécessairement c'est
repartir donc ça fait partie des enjeux
très importants pour nous et encore une
fois comme vous le voyez sur dans des
écosystèmes beaucoup plus larges que ce
qu'on avait précédemment voilà donc avec
des grandes évolutions dans les partages
de la valeur qui vont évoluer oluer au
niveau des acteurs des partenariats très
importants qui se développent des
constructeurs avec toute une série
d'acteurs le repositionnement des
grandes équipes entiers pour finir voilà
on a quand même de la chance on a
au-delà des constructeurs on a des Valeo
on a des forts qui sont bien placés sur
ces logiques là un Michelin également
etc on a aussi des beaux acteurs voilà
donc on a aussi des atouts pour réussir
voilà merci Madame Goslin vous les
reposé une question
je vais demander à ceux qui aujourd'hui
vous écoutent si vous aviez
éventuellement une question Alexis non
merci de nous de cette selon moment
enfin peut-être trop court d'ailleurs
moment d'échange merci de nous envoyer
les éléments qui pourraient nous être
utile et puis ben voilà tout simplement
bon courage pour vous et puis souhaitons
que tous ensemble puissent construire
les bons mécanismes pour aboutir mais je
garde toujours dans mon esprit
un petit inquiétude genre une grande
inquiétude sur la faisabilité je parle
des approvisionnements de matières
premières pour pouvoir voilà et qu'on ne
se mettent pas dans le mur trop vite
merci à vous merci beaucoup merci de
votre écoute merci de votre intérêt pour
ces beaux sujets et à votre disposition
merci beaucoup c'est le rapporteur qui
travaille après